the nfl and the nfl referees association
still finalizing their opt-out
procedures they have 121 officials lined
up to go for the 2020 season
and chris
you consider the demographics
of the
group of officials middle aged and older
yeah they're already out there trying
not to get trampled by the gladiators as
it is
you give them the opportunity to press
pause when you consider because the nfl
for the most part doesn't have full-time
officials they all have other jobs it's
not like they're going to go without
they don't need a stipend they just go
work their other jobs for a year and
then they pick up their careers next
year
i i've
so you're saying full-time officials
that were getting paid a lot of money
might have been a good idea now i mean
that you know it might have been it
might have been a good idea it might
have been a good idea to keep them under
your thumb right nfl right it might have
been a good idea to have full-time
officials because it's gonna be a lot
harder for them to say see you later
we're taking a year off right it's gonna
be a lot easier for the part-time
officials to take that year off and pick
up where they left off next year i
haven't heard any of the details about
what the opt out window with the
standards what the factors will be that
maybe with the officials they're not
going to let them just say
i have no health condition i have no
family situation i have no objective
reason for being concerned i just don't
want to work in the pandemic
maybe it's going to be harder for those
folks to say i'm out because when you
look at how many players have opted out
i have a feeling a significant
percentage of the officials will opt out
and that may be that pressure point that
may be why they don't have a deal yet a
month and a week away from the first
game that counts especially consider it
these officials are being thrust into
the fray this year right there's going
to be more mistakes than ever before
because they don't have training camp
they can't they they don't have
pre-season they can't go to training
camps they can't do the things that
ordinarily they would do to get
themselves ready for the season and so
they're going to be criticized you know
where you think people aren't going to
criticize bad calls they're going to say
oh well let's give these guys a break
they didn't have the access to
pre-season this is gonna be a rough year
for the officials anyway i think it
makes it even more likely that some are
gonna opt out well like the risk is real
i mean you're right hey the referee's
gotta get in the scrub a lot you know
think about oh there's a fumble right
there's two guys in there peeling off
the bodies right doing that oh there's a
fight there's you know guys up in each
other's face yelling each other oh the
referee's got to get in the middle he's
got to get like you know
hit from like mouth spray on both sides
so i understand him being concerned
there definitely now
where you know this is something i wrote
down in my phone over the weekend
you're right they're going to lose like
the
you know pre-season experience getting
some of those plays under their belt but
the one thing that's jumped out to me
about sports so far and especially in in
basketball and and baseball
the fans not being there mike
i think has led to easier games for the
referees i'm seeing less complaining
from nba players right there's no fan
yelling at the referee over his right
shoulder like you suck you're the worst
referee i've ever seen in his life so
he's not dealing with that and i also
think like the players aren't as
embarrassed because there's the fans not
booing or oh you shot air ball and he's
gonna complain and make up some you know
oh i got fouled or whatever else so
it's been somewhat very smooth and i've
enjoyed that about baseball too you know
there's no fans going that's a horrible
call and now you're not seeing the
players you know up you know stay you
know uh upstage the umps and yelling i
haven't seen any of that so that was one
thing i was kind of excited for and then
i saw this and i went oh man now we
might have an f issue with the referees
and it might not even be the normal
referees and if we have backup referees
in a year like this
who the hell knows what happens
especially if they're knocking the
backup referees don't get any reps to
practice or do anything like that that's
when all hell could break loose
and one last note on the way out from
this segment they are going to
specifically construct the crews to be
geographically close to where they're
going to have their games you can have
the same officiating crew pop up time
and again for teams because they want to
minimize the travel for the cruise they
want to eliminate flying wherever they
possibly can they know that they can't
completely eliminate it but it's going
to be a different year for the officials
as well
and the first step is how many will opt
out and before we can get to that point
they have to finalize whatever the rules
are going to be they haven't done it yet
which tells me there's some push and
pull there's some tension there's some
pressure and we'll see if they can get
it worked out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports